lots of 20 20 news to tell you about joe
biden trying to win over moderate voters
by attacking socialist senator bernie
sanders
take a look if you could address our
camera directly
talk to the voters that are worried
about socialism and
you raising taxes first of all i
guarantee a promise
i've never broken my word anyone making
less than four hundred thousand dollars
will not look like a socialist look at
my career my whole career
i am not a socialist and florida's
attorney general is calling for an
investigation
over allegations billionaire mike
bloomberg is buying votes in the state
the former new york city mayor raised
millions of dollars to pay fines for
felons
so that they can cast ballots in
november florida congressman matt gates
saying
it could be criminal i believe there may
be
a criminal investigation already
underway of the bloomberg connected
activities in florida it is
a third degree felony for someone to
either directly or indirectly provide
something of value
to impact whether or not someone votes
so the question is whether or not paying
off someone's
fines and legal obligations counts as
something of value and it
clearly does all right juan
florida statute 104.061 subsection
2. third degree felony
can't do that you can't give someone a
thing of value to influence their vote
and
mini mike's team confessed in a memo
that they have in the washington post
they admit
they say they're not paying fines for
all felons they're just
paying fines specifically for black and
hispanic felons
as an incentive to vote for joe biden
minnie mike's not going to do well in
the slammer
don't worry then because he's not going
i'm teasing but it's not illegal juan
yeah it's legal no it's not of course
it's legal
i'll tell you what's not legal is that
after the voters of florida said that
felons
should be allowed to vote you get
republicans in the legislature changing
the rules so they say oh yeah
but you've got to pay off these debts i
mean basically that's like an indentured
servant that so they
passed that's another inflation no so he
didn't change the rules
the voters of the state of florida in a
political action meant
and intended to benefit donald trump and
that's the illegal action so it would be
like
sheldon nadelson greg out in nevada
saying you know what i'm going to wipe
everyone's gambling debts clean
oh yes as an incentive to vote for
donald trump
that would work on me oh am i in the
hole
bingo was killing me you know um the
dems must be really proud to be the
party of felons
because that's exactly what bloomberg
has inadvertently painted them as
because we know why he's doing this it's
so
uh biden wins florida so these he
assumes felons will vote democrat
and he's put that front and center in
everybody's brain pan
this after the democrats prominent
democrats were bailing out
rapists and murderers and rioters so
they don't give a damn about the victims
they only care about the criminals now i
want to comment on joe biden
joe biden says he beat the socialist yet
he absorbs
all of his principles so he's like a
political pac-man
after he gobbles up the candidate he
just takes
all of their principles or their
policies i
i would assume that if you're the front
runner you would
stick to the issues or the stances that
got you to the front
not just wilt and and just subsume is
that the word dana subsume
thank you it's a good word great word uh
i got it off the word of day calendar
you gave me for christmas in 1993.
but he just absorbs everything because
he has
nothing that's the sad thing he has
nothing
well it has enough to say that he's not
the socialist bernie is a
self-identified
socialist real and the joe we know for
so many years as you guys like to point
out
is a moderate democrat so kennedy yeah
yeah
you have no you're losing let me just
tell you something the candidate being
backed by the communists
the russians
what about the communist chinese one
communist waters right now oh yeah yeah
because we don't want to be right
because
russia they're not the only commies on
the planet in fact you've got commies
that have
a a much much bigger economy in china
and i'm i'm more worried about them and
their election tinkering
frank why is that the fbi says the
russians are the primary actors oh and i
trust the fbi before
everything's
i like the idea of beat the socialist as
some sort of a millennial drinking game
but if if joe biden keeps saying stuff
like that i mean it's better than beat
the bishop if joe biden keeps saying
stuff like that
he's going to get canceled because aoc
came out last week and swore like
joe biden is going to go so far left
after the election you guys we have
nothing to worry about
and don't forget bernie sanders is
writing a lot of his platform
joe biden is not a guy joe biden is a
committee and bernie sanders has a very
important seat
at that committee table so do you think
the bernie bros when they see that sound
on tape they get angry
at sleepy joe i think that the bernie
bros are fickle fans of
biden and they you know next tuesday
we'll have the first debate
and a lot of people are already locked
into their positions republicans are
locked in democrats are locked in
i don't even think there's that many
persuadable voters i'm undecided
oh really yes um i do think that the
the progressive left however if they're
watching the debate
and if they are not satisfied that might
actually be the most important
constituency for biden next week it's a
good point so if if trump
tries to pin him down on being a
socialist and he spends the whole debate
protesting i'm not a socialist the
bernie bros go click
it's like that guy that you the the the
trump supporter with the little uh biden
the
uh bernie supporter with a bow tie that
all of a sudden started voting for trump
you're gonna see that
the voting for trump is a vindictive uh
response you know i think it's a binary
choice
you get biden or you get trump so for
the people on the left
and that is some astute analysis can i
finish thank you thank you
but i think i think for people on the
left who are concerned about they have
to be aware
that it's part of the republican
strategy to try to get
a wedge between them and biden so they
want to promote people in the green
party remember jill stein last time or
they want to promote kanye west remember
him they're still trying to get him on
ballots and there's a clear reason
suppress the votes give the left
more candidates to press the votes i had
no idea oh yeah
no it doesn't you have no evidence
having a proliferation no evidence that
is not suppression
oh no we're not we're not doing it
that's why the trump campaign
stop republicans aren't doing a very
good job suppressing the vote if you
guys won the popular vote last time